SPEAKER 1: Credit card
numbers, birth dates,
phone numbers, names,
addresses, passport numbers--
what do they all have in common?
Cloud DLP can protect them all.
How does it do it?
Stay tuned to find out.
So by now, you know
that de-identification
can be accomplished with a
few different techniques,
each with their own
benefits and features.
But you might wonder, how
does DLP know what's what?
How does it know when
it's spotted a phone
number, for instance,
in the data processes,
and how sure is it?
When DLP inspects data,
the results for any matches
include a certainty score
that we call the likelihood.
The likelihood can be
one of five scores that
range from very
unlikely to very likely.
Likelihood is
important, because it
lets you fine tune the scope
of your de-identification,
and weed out potential
false positives
by setting a confidence
threshold based on likelihood.
How is likelihood determined?
Well, for each of the
120 built-in infotypes,
this score is
determined differently,
depending on the corresponding
infotype detector.
That's the detection
mechanism that matches
on a certain set of criteria.
This criteria could include
pattern matching or checksum.
It can even consider
the surrounding context
that can be
identified in the data
around the potential match.
Time for an example.
Take a look at this string.
What do you think
we're looking at here?
Well, it could be a job title,
followed by an arbitrary
identification number.
On the other hand, it could also
be a person's name and a phone
number.
When we run this through a DLP
inspection job, as expected,
we can get two infotype matches.
Kitty Walker is identified
as the infotype person name,
with a Likelihood
score of likely.
And the 10 digit number
got matched to phone number
with a Likelihood
score of possible.
Now, let's take a
look at the same data
with some positive
context mixed in.
For us, it's a lot more
obvious what we're looking at.
And similarly, Cloud DLP
considers the context
surrounding the data,
and the Likelihood score
jumped to very likely for both
person name and phone number.
DLP's use of context
makes it especially
effective for conversational
text and transcripts.
Once data is inspected
and classified
by infotype and
likelihood, DLP can then
apply de-identification.
So let's talk about one
of the most basic forms
of de-identification--
redaction.
What's redaction?
When working with text,
redaction completely
removes the sensitive values
from your data without a trace.
Poof.
It leaves no clue as
to what was removed.
Let's see how the DLP
API handles redaction
by looking at a request
from a Node.js app.
When we use a DLP API
to inspect content,
we construct a request
object that looks like this.
In the request, we of
course specify the item
that we want to scan.
We also provide an
inspection configuration
that configures the
scanning process.
Here, we can limit the scope
by providing a likelihood
threshold or any
particular infotypes
that we might want
to limit our scan to.
Next, there's a
de-identification
configuration.
This is where we specify
that, with each match,
we want to de-identify
it with redaction.
The response we get
for this request will
have the transform data in
an overview that includes
a summary of the inspection
and transformation
for each infotype found.
For text, redaction is one
of the most simplest forms
of de-identification,
because it leaves
no trace of what was removed.
The same concept can
be applied to images
using image redaction.
In this case, DLP uses
optical character recognition
to find potential
text in an image
and overlays an opaque bar over
any suspected sensitive values.
Let's take a look at
another Node.js request,
this time for this image.
The request object is a
bit different this time.
We, once again, provide an
inspection configuration
where we can indicate
likelihood and infotypes.
We have the option of passing
redaction configuration options
here.
But by default, it'll just place
a black bar only on the text
that it matches.
And finally, we provide the
image converted to a string,
along with the file type.
The response here will be a
new image, this time with bars
covering the redacted data.
Boom.
Our image has successfully
been de-identified,
thanks to image redaction.
So whether you're working
with text or images,
redaction is the
way to go when you
want to totally and completely
remove those sensitive values
from your data.
Although data identification
redaction is powerful,
I did mention that it's one
of the most simplest forms
of de-identification.
Next time, we'll take a look
at a more complex technique
and talk about
de-identification using
crypto-based tokenization.
See you then.
[MUSIC PLAYING]